in general most of the time
hearing people out there have neglected
deaf people
have really
been oblivious and haven't been involved
in deaf culture
and children of deaf adults and disabled
people have been through so much
together
and so we have talent
and there are many ways to tell a story
from different perspectives and
different journeys
and i've just been trying to figure that
out because i just want to make a
connection that gives hollywood more
room for storytelling to think outside
of the box to be creative to tell
stories everyone has stories to tell we
have such a rich history in the deaf
community in the disabled community
and the coda community and we've been
through a lot
and right now it's just a wonderful
opportunity to tell these stories and
this is just the beginning
all right 107 in the back
oh
hi i'm christopher vita tt news agency
um i just wanted to know
what part of this movie are you
or or your performance rather are you
most proud of
really i'm most proud of showing dirty
sign language and dropping f-bombs so
many f-bombs and
i've been so sick and tired of growing
up and i've seen all your swear words
and the subtitles and their foreign
films and all the swearing where was my
opportunity to bring this part of my
culture forward finally here it is
this is the vulgarity now you can
experience it you can just have a taste
and it's such a great flavor welcome to
my world we've been so patient with all
of you and can you be patient with us
deaf people can you learn the rich
diversity of our sign language which
includes our vulgarities you know
lawyers and doctors and scientists we
have so many vocabulary words
mathematicians too but really asl saved
my life because it helped me understand
how to read english and math and science
and theater and scripts and all of the
above
sign language is so rich
everything i've been through in my life
you know we communicate visually as deaf
people it's as simple as that and so now
you know why i wear hats because these
bright lights are so
effing bright and now i'm able to see my
interpreter and so instead of putting a
hand over my eyes looking like an idiot
i can just wear a hat do you all get it
do you get me
thank you